[Musica]
[Applauso]
buonasera
come spoletino diciamo di adozione penso
che sia necessario quasi
non vedo persone molto più conosciute e
vedo molte persone di fuori dire che ci
troviamo nel teatro caio melisso questo
anticamente so quello che vedete oggi è
la l'adattamento che è stato fatto alla
metà dell'ottocento dall'architetto
montironi era l'architetto era stato il
allievo principale di canina a roma e
poi era emigrato in inghilterra per
servire il duca di northumberland per
cui fece due straordinarie e quindi il e
poi tante altre architetture
ritornato a in italia alla metà
dell'ottocento ebbe questo incarico dio
rinnovare il palazzo il teatro perché
questo è stato forse uno dei più antichi
teatri d'italia addirittura nel seicento
era già fornito di tre ordini di palchi
ed era il cosiddetto teatro dei nobili
poi cade piano man piano piano in disuso
fino a diventare novecento nel novecento
era
1950 era il cosiddetto pidocchietto cio
era il luogo di si veniva a vedere tutti
i film di jim della giungla dei già
nargi tutti quanti queste cose qui
poi dopo è stato di nuovo con il
festival a partire dal 1958 è stato di
nuovo rimessa opposto è assunto diciamo
l'aspetto che sono oggi e come tale come
teatro viene utilizzata basta
cominciamo questa chiacchierata che
pensavo di fare insieme con voi ecco io
quando
stefano andrini che avete sentito poco
fa mi ha coinvolto diciamo in questa
operazione qui dicendo ma devi parlare
così via quando ho capito che si partiva
come spesso abbiamo sentito poco fa da
leonardo da vinci ha detto vabbè allora
parlerò dei miei incontri
con leonardo da vinci
perché ho avuto la fortuna di
incontrarlo ben tre volte tre volta
entra in occasioni straordinarie
ecco diciamo che dal minimo è dal 2000
che mi interesso di allestimenti di
mostre di allestimenti appunto di
esposizioni e per per conto con una
volta della casa buonarroti di cui era
l'architetto di riferimento poi ancora
della casa buonarroti ovviamente di
firenze poi ancora appunto di questa
associazione culturale metamorfosi di
roma che allestisce mostre e
sollecitato a loro ho cominciato appunto
a provare ad allestire delle mostre
piano piano ha cominciato per fortuna
per mia fortuna ma cominciavano quelli
che importanti leonardo michelangelo
canova e così via insomma e quindi ogni
volta ho cercato di affinare sempre di
più questa tecnica in qualche modo
perché fare un allestimento significa
innanzitutto confrontarsi con i curatori
scientifici i curatori scientifici
solito sono professoroni sono direttori
di museo sono professori dell'università
e cella che mettono a punto diciamo
qualche modo con idea un'esposizione
un'interpretazione delle opere di un
artista e poi ancora mettono appunto una
un elenco di oggetti che devono essere
messi in relazione fra di loro e devono
essere
dati in pasto diciamo così ai visitatori
allora cosa si fa sì quello che è un
progetto scientifico deve diventare
praticamente un una una
diciamo un allestimento scenografico
cioè quello che aridamente è solamente
un opera dietro l'altro con un quadro un
arazzo una statua e così via devi
diventare invece un percorso di emozioni
deve diventare un uno o più percorsi
dove il l'aiuto delle luci con l'aiuto
dei dei supporti con l'aiuto delle
musiche quando è necessario con l'aiuto
soprattutto delle didascalie tutto
quanto il resto è con un percorso
appositamente studiato si si si tenta di
far capire al visitatore qual è l'idea
del dl di gatta ha inventato la ha
inventato diciamo il percorso originario
qual è l'idea che sottende quello che è
la mostra
ecco io ho incontrato per fare volte
leonardo l'ho incontrato nel 2009 e l'ho
incontrato a roma l'ho incontrato poi
nel 2019 nel 2019 in due posti in due in
due musei diversi in due gallerie
diverse la galleria sabauda di torino e
la galleria dell'accademia di venezia
per l'occasione erano 500 anni dalla sua
morte la prima volta che l'ho incontrato
è stato invece ai palazzi al palazzi
capitolini suoi musei capitolini a roma
ed è stata la prima volta che mi costava
un opera di leonardo ed è stata
un'esperienza della mente straordinaria
diciamo che se ti trovi giorgio sì
diciamo che l'opera è lo gara da esporre
[Musica]
eccolo si va bene grazie all'opera di a
scorrere era questa è un ritratto di
musico si chiama ritratto di musico e
proprietà della della della biblioteca
ambrosiana di milano che non sarà mai
spostata da milano della biblioteca fu
prestato appunto ai musei capitolini
unica opera è un'opera poi molto piccola
vanno granché questa misteriosa come
tutte le opere quasi di leonardo è un
ritratto cioè circa 40 cm 45 cm x 33 una
cosa del genere
quindi immaginate meno di un foglio
formato a4
ed è pronto a basta e di ritratto di
musico perché perché questo gentiluomo e
dei file di circa la metà del
cinquecento della seconda metà del
cinquecento regge con la mano destra un
una carta sulla carta c'è un pentagramma
cioè e cinque righe del pentagramma ci
sono delle note ritratto di musico ma
sappiamo altro però è un po vera
delicatissima è un'opera estremamente
affascinata affascinante diciamo che è
un'opera seducente in qualche modo e poi
e l'abi il problema grande vicelli
quando mi dissero di esporre questa
opera
il fatto era costituito dal fatto che il
luogo che avevano destinato dove esporre
quest'opera ripeto la delicatissima era
il giardino il giardino romano il
giardino romano e quella straordinaria
vetrata che copre una gran parte dei nei
cortili dei palazzi capitolini dove
viene custodita lo è conservata la
statua di marco aurelio quella originale
perché quella che sta in piazza o è una
è una cosa e poi ancora ci sono
tantissime altri altri oggetti e diciamo
di archeologici importanti come la mano
di costantino col dito alzato il
positivo al cera quindi per impedire uno
che la luce rovinasse il dipinto e poi
ancora per impedire che questo dipinto
fosse in qualche modo soffocato tutto
quanto quello stava attorno inventai una
specie di teca andiamo avanti
ecco questa è una versione sono metrica
della teca l'oggetto l'oggetto era
costruito in legno ovviamente in di
fugato e tutto quanto il resto andiamo
avanti questo è il modello
e poi ancora
c'è una sezione in cui si capisce quale
era stata la trovata diciamo in qualche
modo importante devo avanti e questa
cioè l'opera era chiusa dentro questa
specie di tabernacolo questa specie di
teca era illuminata giusta ed era
illuminata dall'alto e quindi non c'era
nessuna ombra che si proiettava sulla
bra stessa
l'opera era posizionata la distanza
giusta di visuale è all'altezza giusta
poi ancora l'opera era su una non era
appesa alla parità appoggiata sulla
parete ma era appoggiata su una tavola
che non si vedeva dietro alla tavola
c'era una piccolissima luce per cui
quest'opera i cui limiti non si vedevano
galleggiava nel buio assoluto di questo
tabernacolo andiamo avanti
ecco questo è l'oggetto questo è il
giorno dell'inaugurazione e o avanti
ecco è questo era il rapporto questi gli
stessi veniva istituire praticamente
darà il visitatore il che guardava
attentamente che era da solo al massimo
due persone potevano sostare
entrava direttamente in collegamento
diciamo in qualche modo con l'opera
stessa cioè interrogava l'opera e
otteneva le risposte in qualche modo
quindi era un rapporto diretto
emozionante di veramente e seducente
andiamo avanti
la seconda volta che ho incontrato come
dicevo prima l'ho incontrato leonardo
questa è la pianta della galleria della
galleria sabauda a torino la galleria
sabauda è come vedere qui ci avevo span
tantissimi spazi però l'opera più
importante tra tante altre di avanti che
erano all'interno della mostra come
disegni e chiaramente di leonardo sam e
seducenti straordinari e andiamo avanti
c'è ancora un altro piuttosto bello di
di anatomia questo qui ha ancora andiamo
avanti ecco il disegno più importante
era il cosiddetto
autoritratto quello che viene definito
l'autoritratto
in questo caso mi trovai a fare una
scelta molto forte cioè i solai
completamente questa che era l'opera più
importante erano circa 70 anni
dell'organico aperta ancora perché non
meri ha aperto il baule in quella
conservata al buio il tutto quanto il
resto andiamo avanti per cui anche in
questo trovai questa sezione numero 4
c'è una stanza praticamente quasi tutta
dedicata completamente a lui e basta che
stava in fondo a questa stanza stretta e
lunga su un fondo completamente nero e
illuminato al massimo possibile al
massimo possibile sono massimo 50 lux
per capirci non certo quello che ci
abbiamo optato per cui anche qui in
questo caso poi se puoi tornare un
attimo indietro c'era un immagine che
interessava anche in questo caso è tutto
buio ma nella nel monitor che ciò io ci
sono due persone presenti
contemporaneamente che stanno guardando
intensamente questa opera è un'opera
anche questa inutile che mi prolunghi
insomma sulla qualità e sull'importanza
di quest'opera andiamo avanti
ecco invece è molto più complessa che
quella all'accademia di venezia quando
mi trovai con questa ex chiesa che sta
al secondo piano dell'accademia e
soprattutto mi trovai con una con
quella di torino era intitolata leonardo
da vinci
disegnare il futuro questa era invece
intitolata leonardo da vinci l'uomo e
misura del mondo l'uomo a misura del
mondo
questa qual era lo bracca importante
aiuta quanto all'esposizione era l'uomo
vitruviano cioè l'uomo per le braccia
alzate e le braccia drift non è solo il
modello diciamo fanno dell'eccellenza
ma è proprio come una misura la misura
dell'universo in qualche modo mi trovai
appunto con opere che erano estremamente
diverse insomma
dipinti statue sculture libri e così via
per cui fu il suo no fui costretto la
mia scelta fu quella di anche qui
inventare una teca un luogo
completamente chiuso dove il disegno che
ha un formato questo sì tipo a quattro
era gioca mente illuminata illuminato al
massimo 50 lux non di più mentre tutto
quanto il resto doveva essere fortemente
illuminato per cui ho dovuto richiuderla
un'altra volta come un po come la prima
soluzione giù in fondo nell abside vede
della sezione su in alto
era questa questa teca vediamo le
fotografie ecco questo e durante
l'allestimento questa e l'ambiente ci
stanno ancora tutti ottanta le opere
messe alle pareti ma coperte ancora e
giù in fondo vedete la teca in un colore
argento in argento proprio a cui si
accedeva andiamo avanti si accedeva con
una lunga passerella per ci sono tre
gradini e quindi dovevo superare questo
questo questo ostacolo in qualche modo
però allo stesso tempo era bello questo
pd vedere la gente incolonnata che piano
piano saliva arrivava leggeva come dire
interrogava il quale in qualche modo
riceveva le sue risposte
e poi ancora si allontanava ecco questo
questa è stata andiamo avanti siamo
ancora un'immagine
in cui si vede già all'opera montata
all'interno e poi ancora ce ne dovrebbe
essere una in cui si vedono
ecco si vedono due persone cioè questi
si stanno montando ancora all'opera e
più di questo non cioè quindi di fronte
a questa apertura verticale si sostava
s'interrogava di volo per in qualche
modo si otteneva le risposte per si
volevano ottenere e poi si allontanava
cioè tutte e tre le volte praticamente
che cosa ho fatto fatto in modo che la
lettura dell'opera la visione dell'opera
se disturbata assolutamente da niente ho
fatto in modo che si entrasse
direttamente in colloquio con l'opera si
ci si potesse come dire fondere con
quella
cioè sentirne le vibrazioni sentirne la
forza e tutto quanto il resto quindi il
quello che so una cosa così una cosa
importante non ho mai partecipato a
prova allestito 50 60 mostre non su
quattro non ho mai partecipato a nessuna
inaugurazione
ma sono tornato più volte in incognito a
vedere le reazioni a vedere non le opere
che tanto le conoscevo anzi lavoro
dovuto studiare la misurate aveva
stabilito dove metterle come me per
leggere sono andato sempre con curiosità
di vedere qual era
qual era il la reazione delle persone
come le persone reagivano come le
persone si relazionavano con quell'opera
in che modo la incontravano in che modo
la lasciava e qui è venuto veramente
questa rivelazione molto importante che
adesso li farò ma è supportata da fatti
scientifici cioè l'opera d'arte la
fruizione dell'opera d'arte fa bene non
solo lo spirito fa bene anche al corpo
ti mette in pace le non solo con te
stesso ma con tutti quanti gli altri ci
saranno delle bellissime ci sono dei
bellissimi studi fatti dall university
college of london che sono circa tremila
studi che sono stati fatti che ti
dimostrano come la frequentazione di
un'opera d'arte è un'opera d'arte
intendo qualunque opera d'arte può
essere un bel libro può essere un bel
film può essere un bello spettacolo
teatrale può essere una musica può
essere
una un quadro può essere un concerto e
proseguirà ti rilassa ti mette in pace
con te stesso cioè in grado di guarirsi
di ferite dello spirito sicuramente di
farti stare meglio in qualche modo c'è
questo
setting del
university college di londra che ha
messo a punto la neuro estetica una
branca diciamo neuroestetica è lo studio
di come reagisce una persona come dire
in un colloquio con un'opera d'arte il
rapporto con un'opera d'arte bene c'è
una foto c'è e ha individuato una parte
del cervello che nella parte centrale
che viene stimolata fortemente e più
fortemente viene stimolata più e il
benessere che uno ne ricava ecco e
questo è importante significa che la
bellezza significa che la mostra cioè
che la mio mestiere non è solamente un
fatto estetico è un fatto emozionale che
la bellezza che l'arte è una sorta di
medicina del nostro essere nel nostro
modo di relazionarci con con il mondo
che ci abbiamo attorno ecco questa è una
grande scoperta è quando non curando un
allestimento to
adoperando tutti i mezzi possibili e
immaginabili su quelli normali che sono
le luci che sono le didascalie che sono
la posizione dove metti questo oggetto
l'altezza dove la posizione le luci che
gli dai e così via in che modo lo
incontra il visitatore magari
all'improvviso magari al centro di una
stanza oppure dietro nanoro è che ti che
quindi comportano diciamo la scoperta la
meraviglia eccetera ecco quando riesci a
raggiungere questo significa che il tuo
mestiere l'hai fatto e l'hai fatto bene
grazie